your next comedian goes by the name
oh you know what yeah let's do that i
like that idea actually
last week to start the show we had a
one of our favorite asian comedians come
up and sing the national anthem to start
things out
and as a gratitude for him doing that
we're gonna give him
a minute here tonight ladies and
gentlemen it's hans kim everybody
i wanna hear it again oh near the answer
here he is
fresh haircut hanson
hey what's up guys i'm asian
good to be here in the south i'm also a
southerner i'm from south korea
there's only two things i like shooting
commies and k-pop
real southerner my asian friends make
fun of me
because i like to eat general says
chicken
they're like hans isn't generoso just a
shitty americanized version of something
authentically asian
and i'm like yeah but so am i
my favorite movie is rush hour 3.
i think my favorite marvel movie would
have to be the black panther because it
gave black children a hero they could
finally look up to
and not just someone like martin luther
king jr malcolm x or harriet tubman or
thurgood marshall rosa parks with my
angelou
kofi and nelson mandela jco brahma oprah
jackie robinson muhammad ali
now there's a fake person that dresses
like a cat
wow
thank you
wow that is how it's done my friend
thank you so much is how it is done
my goodness look at you
that is absolutely incredible hans how
long you been on stand up again
eight years eight years you live here in
austin correct
yes so you're available you're in town
right yeah doing gigs you did the death
squad gig on thursday how'd that go for
you
it went great i love thank you red ben
for having me and that's a brand new
minute right there you just did an
episode with
uh with uh what was that one that came
out last week
uh russell peters and ron white yeah
that was the one before that
oh god well lord vader it was uh
mean last week
no that was here the one that aired last
week
the one that aired last week oh jessica
michelle jessica michelle singleton
right
i was on with russell peterson oh okay
it was that episode
how did i see that you were on it have
you been on multiple times
i've been on twice right and that's not
counting the national anthem last week
so i'm gonna tell you something here
i'm going to tell you something very
very interesting
in the current condition of kill tony
david lucas has to take off
a couple weeks every month to take care
of his baby mama
[Applause]
um or his babies not his baby mama
and uh we have not announced a new
regular on the show in literally
thank you oh yeah in literally years
years it has been years
since we made michael lara regular years
since david lucas a year since william
but any time one of those three guys
can't make it
which is quite often as you will find
out
would you be willing to be the new
regular here on kiltoni
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
[Music]
hell yeah very very exciting what a
brilliant political move on my part
[Laughter]
we need more asian comedians
redband and i had no intention of doing
this until halfway through your set when
you were getting huge laughs we started
the conversation the decision was made
immediately
how do you feel right now hans i feel
amazing i feel like all the years of
homework have finally paid off
that's right
well hans here you are the first ever
fourth regular of the show the third
wheel which is fitting because that's
how many wheels are on a rickshaw
uh okay people don't know what a
rickshaw is that's okay
i'll take it it'll get laughs on the
internet that one
hans very very exciting stuff that was
an
absolutely incredible set snag yourself
one of these big joke books on you have
you gotten one yet have i given you
i have one oh okay forget it then we'll
save the leather
and uh guys i mean i'm so excited about
this how loud can this place get for the
newest regular of kill time thank you so
much
love you all soon
[Applause]
yeah absolutely
i started smoking cigarettes three weeks
ago again
yeah and then
look at the comedians going crazy
they're jumping up and down
wow that is so cool
i love the support austin comedians
supporting austin comedians
honestly uh he's one of my new favorites
uh ever since he moved out here i've
i've really enjoyed his comedy
you can actually see him thursday here
at vulcan doing a set at the death squad
secret show also so there you go
hans kim is in the mix you guys just
witnessed history